Let me get this straight. You mean to
tell me Muhammad Hijab went from calling
me desecrated to getting desecrated by
you just a couple weeks later, right?
>> [music]
[singing]
>> Yeah, guys. I know there's been a lot of
hype, a lot of things going on. We just
had a dollar destruction and it is going
viral. It's all over the place and it
couldn't be any better timing, could it?
I think that it was divine timing. God
is good. He good. [laughter]
God it God won't he do it? God will do
it. So but but why why do you say that
it's divine timing? Like what what makes
the timing of Muhammad Hijab's
humiliation kind of seem like it's
orchestrated by the Lord himself? Well,
you know, it's funny. I'm going to break
down the timeline. Cuz you were supposed
to debate Muhammad Hijab before.
Yeah. Yeah, he called us out before.
On Tuesday, show up at this particular
time. But I didn't have enough
subscribers actually at the time. Right.
It never happens. Okay, so fast forward
April 2026. Him and Libiyano Yep. drop a
video God Logic's wife's a
Muhammad Hijab even says I've been
desecrated.
Then just a couple of weeks later, he
gets desecrated by you.
>> STUMPED ON. INTELLECTUALLY MOLESTED. FOR
TWO hours straight. That was incredible.
>> Yep. And that and that's how we respond.
You know, we could have had the personal
insults back. We could have dropped a
video, you know, talking about him being
bankrupt and losing his lawsuits and the
hotel dramas and the different wives.
>> And a lot of people wondered because
some people don't know how you move. So
a lot of people were like, "Man, God
Logic didn't really respond to that. If
somebody disrespected my wife like that,
I would do this, this, or that." Some
were like, "Oh, yeah, why doesn't he rip
the Quran? Why doesn't he do this or do
that?" People don't know the way you
move is very calculated.
>> Yep. You are going to wait for the right
opportunity to do something your way.
Yep. You have your own way of dealing
with these things. And that's by cooking
dudes. Yep. Embarrassing you on your own
platform. Now, I'm not going to go after
you personally. I'm going to go after
your prophet. You're going to lie about
my wife, I'm going to tell the truth
about your prophet. And that's how we
respond. So, we did an entire episode
reading the best stories about Muhammad
and Aisha and having her scrape up the
semen off his clothes and, you know, the
stained walls and all the kinds of
stuff, you know, very good stories.
Um Yeah, you know, the craziest thing to
me was I think there was a part of their
video where they were like, "Oh, she had
a boyfriend before. She's been
desecrated." Not knowing that they were
insulting the wives of Muhammad because
They all had boyfriends or They had
husbands [laughter] before. In fact, the
only one who didn't have one before was
Aisha. Yeah, but she was in she was uh
you know, she had somebody in line for
already before Muhammad. So, yeah, that
little girl, she was she was getting
some action. Now, on top of this though,
on top of the
Can you Can we make the video?
>> [laughter]
>> Goodness. Anyway, so, what happens is is
that we we we we hop on Muhammad Ali
Jaber's stream, absolutely decimate him.
Um but this it seems like the the
Muslims have been trying to come at you,
defame you, slander you in order to get
to me in order to get a reaction.
>> funny because usually how it's happened
in the past is that they'll come for me
after you bury them. Like, after you
cook them and get them talked feared and
get them slandered and hated on, that's
usually when they'll come for me.
>> Yeah. I'm used to it. I don't even pay
it any mind at this point. Cuz I know
what it comes from. It comes from the
pain of having been in the pot.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> However, this time it happened in the
reverse. So, first Mohammed Hijab came
for me and then you hopped on his panel
and cooked him for 2 hours straight.
>> Yep. And that was the best stew I've
ever made. You guys can go ahead and
make sure you guys watch that. If you
haven't watched that yet, God Logic
versus Mohammed Hijab, absolute
humiliation. He pumped up his chest,
talked about his degrees, but
unfortunately for Mohammed Hijab, none
of his degrees prepared him for me. No,
no they didn't. Now, tell me, you know,
no, first I want to talk about when you
first came up because a lot of people
would not have been able to do what you
did. And I see a lot of comments saying
that like especially after how he was
talking about me, for you to come on the
panel, you were composed, you were cool,
you were chopping it up, you were
laughing, you came in very humble.
>> Yeah. You came in like a dove. Mhm. Mhm.
Gentle like a dove, but
>> Gentle like a dove. As a serpent. That's
right. So, tell me, how was that for
you? Was that tough? No, that's it's not
close to tough.
>> [laughter]
>> Cuz that's you. People don't know, this
is you all day every day, unbothered.
>> Yeah, like genuinely, it's it's not one
of those things where you act like you
don't care or whatever. I I people
people like Hijab, the the arrogant,
prideful, puffy head morons, those are
the ones that get me excited the most.
Yeah.
>> Because the more they're puffed up, the
more they showcase their pride and
showboat, the greater their
humiliation's going to be. And I'm just
I'm just excited about that moment when
that happens. Yeah. And so and and how
many people it's inevitable. [laughter]
And how many people are going to see
that and the people how how how it's
going to affect the audience and the
aftermath of that within their own
because you as you say after I talked to
them and cooked them the aftermath
Muslims start talk fearing them calling
them stupid calling them out Jake the
Muslim metaphysician calling out Libyano
and all this all this in fighting. Jake,
what's up with the with the tweets, man?
Libyano like when you say he got baked
baked about what exactly?
>> He got baked in his conversation with
God Logic when they were talking about
essential hypostatic properties. This is
what happens after they face me.
>> Usually that's what happens. They get
bullied and then they try to bully me.
Never works out very well for you.
>> so he tried to bully you and therefore I
had to go and bully him.
>> That's right.
>> own platform. I so I usually have the
big picture in mind. Like I I want to
keep I want to stay here as long as I
can. I'm on their panel. I'm on the it's
an away game. I'm on their panel and so
I want to stay as much as I I don't want
them to give it I don't want to give
them any reason to kick me. I want to
keep you as long as I can to showcase
how stupid how arrogant you are and how
empty you are. I understand it cuz I
like to cook. So it's kind of like any
dish that you're making you turn on the
oven or you turn on the stove. You're
not going to put it all the way on high
instantly. You're going to let the heat
build. You're going to
simmer. You're going to let the flavor
build. You're going to let all the
spices and everything come together and
you babe are a master chef.
>> I praise God. No, for real.
>> [laughter]
>> That's what we do, man. All all of this
is stemming from what we have done to
them in this ministry. We're destroying
them. They can't debate us. They can't
beat us and so they try to attack us try
to intimidate us. There's been a lot of
that going on. Yeah, there has been.
>> Uh Balboa Balboa Park where that boy
tried to you know get up close to you
close to you bump you.
>> And buddy understanding physical
maturity Don't don't cover him up. Don't
cover him up. Don't cover Hey brother.
[laughter] Brother, just real quick
Michelle. First love.
Yeah, I mean you to step away from my
wife, please. No, no, no, out of
respect, step step away from my wife.
No, step away. She's asking. Okay,
brother, I DON'T WANT TO GET PHYSICAL.
HE
handed me the camera and everything.
>> restraining order after that, after
trying to after uh bumping into you and
stuff like getting checked. Like this is
how weird Dawah is. They can't debate
us, they can't beat us, and so they try
to dox us, intimidate us, slander and
lie about us, spread rumors.
>> Literally nothing but lies. That's the
funny part because when Libyano, when he
made that video, I think even most of
the Muslims in the audience knew he was
lying. The ones that know him, like the
ones on TikTok and that crew, they know
he's lying. Yeah. Everybody knows he's
lying. But um Oh, it was funny.
>> called him out in the in the audience.
>> I saw that.
>> comment section, they called him out and
was saying, "You shouldn't do this. You
have no proof." And yada yada yada.
>> what he did after that, right?
>> do? So, he was getting backlash from
Muslims, and so he made some caption
saying, "Before you start feeling sorry
for this Jezebel, just know she
blasphemed our mother Aisha." Something
I've never done. First of all, No way.
>> I feel sorry for Aisha. I would never
say anything mean about her. She was a
young victim.
>> for Aisha.
>> That's all I'll ever say. Justice for
Aisha. I would have nothing negative to
say about the girl. Is she a what?
>> Um yeah.
>> Hey, that that ain't our business. Hey,
that ain't Yeah, that's not my battle to
fight. But he had to lie and say he had
a good reason for doing what he did.
>> Yeah. When his real reason is just that
he desperately wants your attention.
>> Yeah,
unfortunately.
>> It was sad cuz even after you begged
hijab for 2 hours, he came running up.
>> up and beg for more attention. That That
boy is the That boy is the biggest
pick-me show I've ever seen. You got to
play a little hard to get. It was sad,
but also it was a bad look because I
think when he jumped up, he was saying
he was trying to accuse Nick of helping
you, which I know isn't true cuz I was
there. And it's funny cuz he was hopping
up to help Muhammad Hijab. It it's it's
it's hypocritical. He's They're
Let's say I was receiving help. Let's
say I was receiving help.
Uh people sending me sources or
whatever. Uh let's say I'm receiving
help. Is that Is that a bad thing?
It wouldn't be a bad thing.
>> It But they said it would be a bad
thing. I don't know. I think you were
doing so well that they had to accuse
you of getting help because they
underestimate.
>> But I'm just Like let's think about
their mindset. They're saying that
that's a bad thing, right? While
Muhammad Hijab is doing it the entire
video.
>> Literally getting the phone handed to
him. Can't read, doesn't know the
Hadith, has to have the Hadith handed to
him. Getting doesn't know the sources
with all those books behind him. Has to
have the source
uh passed to him. He did He didn't know
the Hadith. I had to tell help him out
of finish the Hadith cuz he didn't know
the Hadith. Now that is Let's talk about
that moment right quick. Hold on cuz
that was one of my favorite moments. So
that was Sahih Bukhari 7362, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. You knew You know that one by
heart. He did not know it. And when he
wouldn't finish it, tell me what were
you thinking in that moment? Cuz I was I
was watching it and I was feeling like I
was watching Steph Curry. This is This
is one of those things where the person
you're debating makes things worse for
themselves.
>> MHM. YOU [clears throat] YOU WARNED HIM.
>> YES. I said
>> make me embarrass you.
>> me embarrass you. Please don't do it.
Ooh. I was feeling secondhand
embarrassment. Yeah. This is This was
tough. But that's that's what I'm
thinking. I'm like I'm trying to help
you, man. I I feel this way with all of
them. But at the same time, it's I'm
going to humiliate you if you keep this
up. It's It's going to be bad. And so
>> It's going to be a clip.
>> Yeah. So in in in real time, I'm I'm
seeing how how bad this is getting. And
how Sensi's refusing to finish the
Hadith. Now there's two things. Either
he's not finishing the Hadith because
he's ignorant and doesn't know it with
six degrees or he's lying. He knows it
and he knows that it backfires against
them was hoping I didn't know about it
and therefore he's trying is desperately
trying not to finish it because it
backfires when Muhammad says say to the
people of the book we believe in what
was revealed to us and what was revealed
to you. So they can't believe in parts.
They can't be agnostic. You got to
believe in the Bible just like you got
to believe in the Quran. I'm leaning
towards the opinion that he didn't know
it. He saw that part got excited and was
very very hyped cuz he thought he had a
gotcha and he hadn't read the rest yet.
And then as soon as he read the rest he
was like oh my gosh. And so he tried to
do anything he could not to finish it.
>> Anything he could, yeah. But him not
finishing it made him look worse because
the Muslims were like why won't he
finish it? I know some of them were
thinking that.
>> Yeah. And so and now here's the thing
for our Muslim listeners and for future
people who I might, you know, who might
be a future interlocutor or something.
Listen. The best move in a conversation
in a dialogue is to be honest. That's
the best move. Be honest and be humble
because if you're not you're going to
end up like Muhammad Hijab. You're going
to end up like Flip piano. You're going
to end up like Hamza's Den. You're going
to end up like Mansour. You're going to
end up like every last one of them. Jake
Jake from Muslim metaphysicians. Ali
Dawah.
>> Ali Dawah. You're going to look like all
of the Infinity Stones that I've
collected so far in this journey. So
Yeah.
>> stay humble and stay honest.
>> Speaking of being humble
you came in very humble. By the end you
were in full
full
>> [laughter]
>> flow state. You were in your zone. You
were in your mode. You were just you had
on your chef hat, you had on everything.
How did it feel when you got to that
moment? Did you know like, "Okay, I
bodied this."
Yeah, it was it was it was a wrap. Cuz
it was already bad when it started. 1094
he was fumbling on that, didn't know
where to go. So at this point it was
Muhammad got him on that and then it was
the Furqan thing.
>> Yes, ooh. And so once that it was once
that got heated up, I was like, "Okay,
yeah." But you know why it wasn't over
right there. But what? Because after
that he had to keep going with you to
get a moment. That's why he wanted to
flip over to Christianity and I honestly
think if he hadn't done that, he might
have been all right.
>> [laughter]
>> I don't know. But Live and Law? Yeah.
That was tough to watch.
>> didn't know about it. Only you could
almost make me feel bad for Muhammad
[laughter] Hijab after what he was
saying about me.
But I almost felt bad for the dude. I'm
I'm being so sincere. The second-hand
embarrassment was There's he's deleting
comments. They're deleting comments on
his on his stream on his video that he
posted.
>> Did he not even I think he turned the
comment section off.
>> let me let me hold on. Let's actually
share what some of the Muslim comments
were saying on his video on his stream.
Muhammad Faaz who says, "As a Muslim, I
have to admit that Hijab didn't deal
with his argument. I kind of felt like
he was ignoring all the questions."
There's an honest Muslim. And because
he's an honest Muslim, he's a soon-to-be
ex-Muslim most likely.
>> I feel it. We praying for you.
>> Praying for you, man. Let's see. Let's
see what Let's keep going to see what
other honest Muslims we can get. Dylan
who says, "6 degrees? Bro, you wasted
your time because what the F did I
watch? Disappointed in you as a fellow
Muslim."
>> Ouch. So he's saying all them degrees
for nothing? All them degrees for
nothing.
Your manners suck, your your temperament
sucks, and your argumentation sucks.
>> I'm not going to lie, he scared me a Me
and grandma were watching and when he
started doing all that yelling and
screaming, we saw that demon. That was
very scary. That was a tense moment.
>> whole face and It changed. deformed and
Yeah. Yeah, he was he manifested fully.
Here's another comment, a neutral party.
Says, "I am a neutral person
investigating Islam. My opinion is Hijab
lost this debate. Please set up another
debate with God Logic and prepare
better."
Oh, that's a Is that the last comment
cuz I have a question for you?
>> It's not the last one. We got got a
couple go.
>> Okay, let's hear those and then I have a
question for you.
>> Okay, here's another one.
I'm a Muslim and unfortunately, despite
Muhammad Hijab's best attempt, he wasn't
able to refute God Logic. No Muslim on
Earth will be able to destroy this
so-called dilemma argument until they
know exactly what Al Kitab is.
See? The Muslims are coming out.
>> Well, if you know, please do come up
Monday, Wednesday's, Fridays.
>> [laughter]
>> Uh here's
Here's a
Watch this.
"You destroyed yourself, Muhammad Hijab,
after telling the truth. Your rudeness
outweighed the truth you were talking
about. Six degrees and no manners?
What's the point?
So, notice this. Now, this is a Muslim
who's going to hold on to He believes
that is you know, Muhammad Hijab did
tell the truth like we're in regards to
the religion. He agrees with what
Muhammad Hijab says. However, the
pridefulness, the arrogance, the
interruptions, the belligerence, the
immaturity, he's saying that that
destroyed the truth. It it it's it's a
smoke screen to the truth that you were
actually telling. So, you defeated
yourself. I didn't God Logic didn't have
to do it. Even if you were right, and
though you were right, you destroyed
yourself.
>> And my Bible says pride goeth before a
fall and fall did he. Here's another
one. "I'm on Islam's side, but please,
Hijab, what are you doing?
You just keep on talk and talk, bro.
So, notice, even the Muslims are calling
him out for interrupting, going on
monologues, not engaging with the
arguments. They're able to see this.
This is the one from the same
>> help him. You told him that that exposes
the weakness of his position. When he
can't let you speak because he's too
afraid. And then he can't answer. You
tried to help him.
>> Oh, yeah. He didn't understand that
everyone can see it. Yep.
Here's another one. I like this one. You
ready? Yes. Brother Hijab is better than
this. I am disappointed.
>> No, he's not.
>> [laughter]
>> a lot of love for their brother, man.
They they they they they feeling for
their brother.
Uh, here's another one.
I'm really sad that Hijab didn't win
properly in the Islamic question. Mhm.
So, the part that you're supposed to win
at, Hijab, the part that you're supposed
to be a scholar in, you know the Arabic,
you got your six degrees, you've studied
this, you've debated the top scholars in
Christianity and all kinds of stuff, and
yet you failed in the Islamic portion of
our discussion. Your Muslim brothers are
upset. They're disappointed. Can't make
this up, man. Embarrassed. You lost to a
Christian on an Islamic topic. So, we
read those comments. You absolutely
cooked him. I think that there's no
question. Anybody who's honest knows
that you walked him down. Mhm. Would you
ever take a formal debate with him?
Probably not.
You don't think there's a point? No. Um,
like so, here here's the difference with
uh Muhammad Hijab. One, Muhammad Hijab
I've never had a discussion with him
before, and he's been on my hit list.
>> Yes.
>> Right? He's been on my hit list. I never
had a discussion with with him before.
Wanted to destroy him, embarrass him,
humiliate him, especially for what he
was saying about you. The difference is
that I'm going on there, going on there
before, and then not talking to Liviano.
I've already destroyed Liviano twice.
Yeah. Gave him Gave him another
opportunity to have a third discussion
on my on my platform. Like he said he
would, never came.
>> Played games again when we decided to
co-host. I gave him what he want Okay,
sure. Come Let's co-host on my on my on
my channel, whatever. We can co-host.
Never did it. Never showed up. Stalling.
Said we can do it right now. So, playing
games. Yeah.
>> play games. You're x'ed off now. Yeah.
And then you go on to dox us. You dox us
and then you slander my wife.
>> Yeah.
>> You're You're done. You will never get
my attention again. With Muhammad hijab,
he's in the same boat now. Because
before I never spoke to him, he didn't
dox us, nothing like that. Oh, he did
slander you, which was prompted I'm
about I'm about to go destroy this dude.
>> Absolutely.
>> to go destroy this dude. But then, when
I left, he continued to do it again. He
didn't say nothing about you when I was
on the platform, cuz he know I would
tell the truth about his prophet. Once I
left, he then start calling me a
prostitute and doing Oh, yeah, we pass
him around and and talking about you.
>> Why are all their Why do they get so gay
with the Because they're prophets.
Because the prophet.
>> Because that's why.
Because that's why. You know, it's funny
because
>> wouldn't give him I would I wouldn't
give him another time of day, either.
Yeah.
>> I I think that makes sense to me. That
makes sense to me. You know, it's funny
because we could have sued Muhammad
hijab for defamation, but I
think he's been through enough when it
comes to that kind of thing. I don't
even know if he has the money. So, what
you did to him [laughter]
was so much better. Thank you, babe.
Yeah. I appreciate you. You are a
wonderful, amazing husband. Um Oh. I
couldn't have asked for a better
defense. I mean,
you absolutely desecrated him on his own
platform, and everybody knows it. So,
What's the only thing we do, babe? Man,
we just read, babe.
We just read. We just read.
>> [laughter]
>> They want to know [music] how we know.
Bro never should have wrote what he
wrote. Like he read, just read. Drop a
quote out the quote.
Now they steady trying to quote with no
hope. How can we judge
How do y'all be knowing so much? We got
scholars but nobody shows us.
>> [music]
>> Why you even reading all that? If you
ain't even believing all that.
>> [music]
>> We just read we just